therapiert auf uns jetzt aus nico
zugeschaltet du hast dieses krankenhaus
besucht in sakarya philip kleer erzählt
uns ein bisschen die bilder die du dort
gesehen hast die menschen die wir jetzt
gerade in deinem bericht gesehen haben
was schildern sie dir wie erleben sie
diesen krieg
ja diese liegt dieser junge mann diese
schauen die wir gesehen und gesprochen
haben wir sind der lebende beweis dafür
dass russische truppen gezielt
ukrainische zivilisten angreifen nicht
mutmaßlich wie ich in der tagesschau
heißt sondern tatsächlich an das haben
wir uns diese menschen erzählt und das
zeigt dass wir im ausland kriegs
menschen waren entweder zu hause oder
waren bereits ein problem eindeutig
zivilen ikb
als nicht militärische einheiten waren
in ihren autos sie waren in der wohnung
garten und wurden dort von russischen
truppen beschossen
augenzeugenberichte berichte von
menschen auf die geschossen wird hier
angegriffen werden zivilisten das sind
kriegsverbrechen philipp wenn wir diese
bäder gemeinsam betrachten passiert im
russischen fernsehen das seit langer
zeit wird russische
diese bilder einmal gemeinsam rein sehen
gerade so über die weitere
kriegsstrategie gesprochen
louis blues nutzt alle verhandlungen mit
den nazis sind sinnlos bzw werden als
eine schwäche ausgelegt so lange man
seinen stieg bin ich auf den hals hat
man soll denen nicht die hände schütteln
man wolle mit den kein smalltalk führen
man soll mit denen sich nicht treffen
und nicht sprechen
es wurde eine aufgabe gestellt und diese
aufgabe muss umfassend gelöst werden
philips weiter uns zugeschaltete philipp
das läuft dort in der nachrichtensendung
das ist das was zehntausende millionen
von russinnen und russen im fernsehen zu
sehen kriegen das ist die propaganda die
dort ausgestrahlt wird
ja absolut das macht erstmals los aber
lasst uns einmal analytisch draufschauen
das sind professionelle besten
hochbezahlte menschen die eine ganz
bestimmte funktion haben sie sind in
ihrem ton und inhaltlich deutlich
radikaler als alles ist aus der
russischen politik kommt also radikaler
als versprechen des kreml radikaler auch
als die ansagen des russischen militärs
sie bereiten sozusagen ideologisch den
boden der vor dass kriegsverbrechen
begangen werden das kriegsverbrechen
auch in russland in menschen verkauft
werden können und ich würde natürlich
alles was im busch was muss also
passiert dass das mit und russland
gleichzeitig glauben die menschen weil
sie im angeheizt werden dieser
propaganda eine ganz wichtige brutalität
überhaupt nicht geht das ist eine
ordnung ist ein städte in schutt und
asche zu legen weil ihnen das eben im
fernsehen erzählt wird und dass die
natürlich auch als rechtfertigung um
sich nicht schuldig zu fühlen weil sie
eben sagen können na ja es sind ja nach
können ja nicht mit ihm verhandeln sonst
gehen wir als russische staat unter
vielen herzlichen dank dir für deine
informationen